what a vlog early morning Saturday
you're about to watch a really
interesting meeting I had with two dudes
two great guys from Connecticut I want
real specific advice obviously the
dollar ad stranded you know Instagram
has hit pay dirt for a lot of you the
2017 flipped challenge I'm trying to
force myself to give you guys more black
and white tactical advice I think this
is it this interview kills it enjoy
[Music]
let's cook them nice to meet you nice to
meet you long time
thank you ma'am thank you ma'am so
what's going on what can I help you with
in this short period of time we got
anything specific you remember our
interaction list
mmm-hmm oh yes I'll meet you guys a kind
of Ramone this is at this point looking
to see if I really want to come here see
its environment
I see if this is something I want to
pursue as a personal brand company oh
yes so I still have a physical products
now Amazon Shopify of using partner with
youtubers drive traffic to Shopify
stores yep so this is kind of a turning
point now does that secret enemies you
can see this give me the story from the
gap um so I left my jump up three years
ago I was working at Bank of America but
we kept I fell out I was having my
second shop and decided to leave because
my last chance
is that go ahead so I it's always been
in your dome yeah I've been doing stuff
since I was 16 order from overseas
reselling things mm-hmm
decided about three years ago went right
into like the economy jobs outsourcing
that transition into Amazon eBay shop
and Lefty so you have to do that for
arbitrage arbitrage arbitrage what was
your best kind of what was your best
little run I do a lot of paper products
for like parties so like a baby shower
games wedding photo booth props I like
that I sell a lot of those mm-hmm yeah
it's a good market yeah this past
Pinterest bin and a gateway drug for you
in that world a little bit yeah you can
yeah you should you should man yeah you
get the right pin shake and get
ridiculous I have pin on pictures before
I just don't really always have you
trapped here's the best part you've
heard this from me go home after this
this might be the best thing that comes
out of this meeting yeah
go home and be like how do I get traffic
from Pinterest on Google and just
[ __ ] give me give me ten hours yeah
if you're still playing in that field
you love that field
you give me ten hours of watching videos
reading free content and then start
hacking your one pin away from insanity
and while everybody's looking at
influencers in Facebook in that demo
against that product yeah you get the
right [ __ ] infographic with the right
pin fluence are pinning it like what you
feel from youtube I think can be
compounded by 50 for cheaper because
their markets not as hot so they're
taking money right
but the traffic is bonkers yeah on the
right pin you get the right one yeah
I've been doing bachelorette party stuff
a wedding stuff you need to look at it
man
yeah cuz it's a search engine you get
you get the right pin to be above the
fold you know we're in a fifth one in
the feed around you know invites or
exactly you know you know baby shower
gifts she could get bonkers got it yeah
ten hours yeah just laying in bed
reading watching video something like
okay if that's the you know with 20
about like short interactions you try to
like bring the most value if that's your
answer to my question
then you better get [ __ ] focused on
Pinterest dear cool yeah because it's
all demos right you know it's like we
trying to reach 27 year old kids
snapchat matters 54 year old executives
nope you know so even though Pinterest
hasn't come out of my mouth and [ __ ]
45 episodes yeah it's the answer to that
question everybody's trying to catch
what's hot without being smart about
what they actually sell okay
cool what else so remind me that this
part I can't connect when when our last
interaction wanted to get a taste of
this world for what purpose was a
personal brand I'm more of an introvert
yeah to do things quietly
yeah I I get it my DNA didn't allow me
to but I know the culture was definitely
not where it is now where the
fourteen-year-old thinks they need to be
a star is that so I'm trying to
determine whether that's at my pursue
for what purpose it's to create more
business opportunity how leverage to
more of your retail arbitrage you'll
write a book or speak I don't know if I
want to go in today I don't know if
physical products is really that's
really what I'm chasing
I think physical product will let you
have the lifestyle you want if you make
the commitment to build a brand of
course yeah you know you can let me
phrase you can have a grape you can make
a million dollars I mean there's plain
retail arbitrage it's as you know it's
an always ongoing game but don't get it
twisted so as being a personal brand you
know like you know how it is everything
you know everyone's like oh I wish I was
a barber until late and I wish I was a
basketball player until you are one and
you burn out your knee like the grass
man that grass is green as [ __ ] on
everybody else's lawn no but I but I
your serves other person I'm a certain
type of person I found my zone I get I
mean I sat through a parent-teacher
conference as a group and like four
minutes in I was sleeping you know you
got to play to your strengths or and so
you know if you're naturally an
introvert you don't want to force it
because you think the money's there you
made for sit because okay you're an
introvert because of this but you don't
mind and you don't have to be a showman
just playing people crushing video that
are know keep you know yeah of course
you got good information everything's an
opportunity I really like to try
of course yeah like I'm a huge boxing
fan yeah look I mean yeah it's gonna um
yeah I mean look and I think there's a
listen I get it there's a lot of sex
appeal and being like the mysterious guy
behind the scenes making real [ __ ]
coin I don't think there's anything
wrong with that especially if that's
like anybody who knows how al Haman is
and then puts them on that pedestal I
almost think that's the answer
yeah I do too I over the last two weeks
I've kind of come to that conclusion
yeah I now just started reach out to
youtubers and I'm actually building a
few sites for a few them to run the
emerge dude so I can have the drive to
try to the show I think the biggest
thing that you need to understand the
difference between Al's game and doing
it for influencers as the influencers
have disproportionate more leverage than
the boxers do and they also have
unlimited distribution they can do it
anywhere they want for free they don't
need the money up front Adsense is their
bank you know so I think you're right
but I think it's a very different game
to represent fighters as it is to you
know not to mention representing
fighters when you make a deal with CBS
up front and you've got the leverage and
the dollars and the exposure you can't
fight it anywhere else they're like two
options that's not what an influencer is
dealing with they have eight million
people reaching out to them to manage
and get into their pockets and help them
and make their pockets bigger they have
unlimited distribution they can be big
anywhere snapchat Instagram and Facebook
don't charge got it so just make sure
you're not trying to deploy a strategy
that works in one world theoretically
being behind the scenes making that
point yeah I understood that's where you
meant but make sure you don't try to be
too direct with the blueprint because
the same variables don't exist
yeah what do you let okay okay we're
just mm-hmm
yeah let's go yeah I'm say anything else
that you want to definitely ask um
didn't have any specifics one come here
and see see the see for myself and see
if this is something I want to pursue
good so yeah it's great opportunity for
me yeah tell me back shelf grow up
together Wednesday Connecticut
grew up playing ball very diverse high
school got exposed to a lot and I'm
actually a moonlighter right so I have a
full-time gig director of engineering at
a traveller's right I've got some
Hartford the insurance company yes yes
yes but uh you know as soon as I leave
work tend to the family that I get to
grind it so bill a nice direct direct
messaging so SMS Texas speech and also
he meant yeah so my clients currently
love it just for emerges notification
general distribution of information but
getting in front of their audience on
time
so right now figure it out are you do
you have a SAS business or do you have a
do you have a client service business
assess so yes how are we calm to payment
yeah how's it going so so good so far so
now how are you creating the funnel of
clients where to mouth or you running
some ads so it's gonna be Facebook ads
so just finishing around to the
animation in the new targeted Facebook
ads for your specific demographics love
it anything I can screen you
so market market research was
challenging for me figuring out who yeah
figuring out that it's a tough one for
the administrator right and your utility
it's not yeah you know it's just like if
you don't have if you're gonna have
power you know you don't have gas and
it's cold you feel it yeah yeah
but sometimes you don't even know the
difference is the people when gas wasn't
around in the beginning you didn't know
you were missing it yeah we didn't know
we were missing the cell phone until
it's there I get that so you know base
educating the prospective client can I
give you a really really good piece of
advice running something in a twenty
five to forty mile radius around your
business and then making the piece of
creative being an invite to a free
dinner to talk about messaging all of
sudden you get a collective quit you
know and you make it an RSVP and you put
in the copy first twelve people cuz look
you're gonna have to put out 500 bucks
for dinner super interesting to use
Facebook as the gateway drug to
localized business transactions in a b2b
environment right yes salaries a good I
think salaries always a good one
you know what towns have money versus
ones that don't in Connecticut that's
sometimes a good one employees of the
business is big enough so now you kind
of look at the forty mile radius of the
businesses truth is his product is
pretty agnostic anybody couldn't a lot
of people could in theory use it so I
would cast a wider net just to taste it
see the quality of it you could also
instead of say first twelve say I'm
gonna randomly pick twelve of you that
RSVP to invite to dinner then you see
who RSVPs you google them and look at
their LinkedIn see who they are you pick
twelve best leads good right people
think of technology digital or real-life
I like mixing the two I know that you'll
have a much better I'm gonna bite ya
especially make a video you're like I'm
gonna buy you for dinner I'm gonna steal
my company or a partner my company I'm
gonna buy you dinner and educate you and
shoot the [ __ ] a little bit by the new
judicial world
go all of some people put a name at the
face you know people decide to come come
there's something real human about that
most people are always up for and again
you know what I love about things like
Connecticut you know exactly which
restaurant people you know you know the
seven restaurants people know you pick
one of those maybe you hit up two of
them and be like hey I'm gonna do this
you willing to cover the the cost I mean
like entrepreneurship I would pick the
seven I'd call and be like you know I'm
gonna run this Facebook and I'm gonna
spend thousand dollars just trying to
get people to come to a restaurant you
guys willing to cover the meal yes
we've been meaning to do Facebook
advertising I'll link you in hustle you
know that would work
that's Chamber of Commerce ten point oh
yeah that's it right like that's that's
the you know I think a lot of times
people think that what got me here with
these views is the pizzazz back to
rounding up this whole thing what got me
here was that part yeah you know just
like knowing being a practitioner of
MacGyver like doing and never being
tooth out dude that [ __ ] now never being
too fancy before that and there's like
scale technology you know nope corporate
is coming back so like
you have you have leaders all the way up
to sex and now we get hands on again
they have to yes they're being
commoditized your MBA is nice and cute
until it's not
shit's getting very interesting I'm glad
you guys came down anything else I want
to kind of give it to you why I got you
here ok thanks my picture a hundred
percent you take the selfie yeah horse
not visual a I know I like doing it cuz
I people you know everybody's always got
a there we go
love it let me see the gear well check
yourself now the joke let's go
love it that's right hey take care you
Sunday good luck try that let me know
how that goes here yeah I think it's
gonna work leave it to the four cents
when you thought about this little mean
I had did you get value see ya
[Music]
[Music]